so if you've watched jordan peterson
videos you have most definitely
heard him talk about the pinocchio story
and usually jordan tells a very touching
version of that story where he
encourages people to go down into the
belly of the whale to save their dead
father and he sees this as an image of
how
the father represents the past the
father represents that which came before
you
and in some ways it is always dead and
we need the sun we need an
actualizing principle which goes back
into the past or back into that which
has been given to us
and makes it
live again makes it uh
adapts it to the current situation and
jordan usually uses the image of uh the
story of
of osiris and horus with isis and set as
kind of the mythological backdrop for
this story but i've also noticed that a
few times i've seen jordan struggle to
understand how this story jives with the
story of the death and resurrection of
christ he seems to see the story of the
death and resurrection of christ as a
kind of flip and virgin of that where it
is the father that resurrects the son
and i've and i've seen him struggle to
kind of understand that so i thought
i've been thinking for years to make
this video but for some reason i'm just
doing it now so i thought that we would
look at the manner in which christ saves
his father from the underworld how
ultimately not only he does that but it
is what we could call the ultimate
version of that story and it also
restores the notion this the difference
between the fallen father and the true
father or the the father that is the
source of all things
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
so the manner in which jordan
caught on to this story i think is is
very powerful and
he is able to gather a lot of insight
from his interpretation of the myth of
of osiris and horus and also the story
from pinocchio so there's a sense in
which
the
the father is dead the father is the
past the father is this this stuff
that's been given to us this tradition
that comes before us but that somehow
has
is not living and breathing and so the
manner in which you make it living and
breathing is by paying attention that's
why jordan talks about this notion of
the eye of horus as being this note this
attention which gathers all this past
all this potential into actuality and
makes it alive makes brings it together
in a way that can be
acted with acted on acted within
and
he of course views the story of
pinocchio as one of the most beautiful
versions of that because pinocchio in a
manner
is made by his father as something which
is not fully a boy and by going down
into the belly of the whale going down
into death and saving his own father he
at the same time becomes a real boy
becomes a real person and of course
there's much to learn from that in terms
of
understanding how
you know if we're able to give meaning
bring together that which has been
handed down to us make it actual then it
will also be the source of our own
capacity to exist in the world in our
own capacity to kind of
to be something yeah and so
but like i said one of the issues that
jordan has had is seeing that this
doesn't seem to be the case in the story
of christ like wisely the christ dies
christ is the one that dies you know
goes into death and then his father is
the one that resurrects him
and so
the way in which we need to understand
this is because we have to look at the
greater tradition we could say in order
to properly understand the story of the
resurrection of christ how it connects
to this particular strain of
storytelling we have to see the whole
thing
um and so in the christian story there's
something which is hinted at of course
in the scr in scripture but is
elaborated in images
and in a more
story form a bit later in the story of
christianity and it's something that we
call the descent into hades or the
descendant to death we see a narrative
version of that in the gospel of
nicodemus we see versions of it in the
icon of the anastasis that we call where
we see christ going down into death now
in this image what we see is we don't
see christ going down into death
only as the one that is the victim but
now we see the inverse of that which is
that the secret thing that's happening
on the cross when christ is sacrificing
himself he is ultimately secretly a
victor he is the one that's why we have
this idea of jesus christ victor if
you've seen a cross a greek cross with
it says you know jesus christ nica
which means jesus christ the victor
so what we see in this image in this
icon is we see christ going down into
death and what he's doing is he is
saving adam he is actually saving adam
and eve
and this is the version of the pinocchio
story that the christians have which is
that in sacrificing himself christ is
ultimately saving his father now not his
heavenly father he is saving his fallen
earthly father by doing that there are
many things that are going on one of the
things that's happening is we're
noticing that
how can i say this adam in the story of
scripture is seen as let's say the
source of all the problems because he is
the one that ate the fruit of the the
knowledge of good and evil adam and eve
are the ones that started this whole
problem the problem that christ is
coming to solve and so by saving adam he
is in a manner saving all the fathers
he's not just saving his own father he's
saving all the fathers and he is
covering for his father's uh lack by his
own self-sacrifice now of course you can
see how this fractally applies
to your own life which is that we as
people we can cover for the sins of our
parents this is an image that we see in
the story of noah for example where you
know noah at the end of the flood
he finds himself drinking and drunk in
his tent
and uh you see his sons
his his uh one of his sons comes and
makes fun of him you know in the tent
and laughs and tells his brothers about
what's going on
and the two the other two brothers they
come in and they walk backwards and they
cover their father
now this is one of the things that we
can do which is to walk backwards and to
cover the sins of our father and so how
do we do that we do that by
seeing the sins of our father
but instead of
blaming our father instead of blaming
our our parents for all our problems we
rather cover their sins we cover their
sins by our own transformation we cover
their sins by our own self-sacrifice
that is what my father was a jerk my
father was a bad father who didn't care
for me well i am going to cover the sins
of my father not by blaming him not by
accusing him but rather by becoming the
father that he wasn't by taking care of
my own kids and by doing that what i'm
doing is i'm actually
honoring my father and mother i'm
honoring my father in a way that
that that is not naive right i know that
my father had all these sins but i'm
doing it in a manner in which i'm going
to represent i'm going to manifest
something else and cover over his sins
and so this is of course
this is of course one of the things that
the story of the resurrection is
revealing to us so what we see is that
christ going down into death and doing
exactly what pinocchio did going down to
death to save his father he is saving
all the fathers he is he is bringing
this story to its limit let's say he is
showing the totality of what this story
is which is that he is saving the father
of all fathers the very first man the
one
for whom you could blame all the
problems of all humanity on if you
wanted to that is the one that he is
saving and and by doing that he is in a
manner act re-actualizing adam he is
himself becoming the new atom and he is
let's say creating a new origin as well
for all of us now that is one of the
things that happens in that story now
the other thing that happens in the
story is that it is also
helping us understand that the the
notion that the father that god the
father represents tradition or dead
tradition is not of the right way to
understand trinitarian theology the the
idea of understanding the father as the
dead father or the dead tradition the
dead law all of these types of of um
interpretation which are completely uh
accurate which are very insightful
is about adam it's about
the manner in which everything in adam
which is fallen and it is this dead
letter this dead law all of this but
what it does is that it all it is true
that in this story the father resurrects
the son so the son goes down into the
into death
to save his father
and then he is resurrected by the
heavenly father so what does that mean
what is that referring to
and so there is a manner in which
the father is the source of you
quite simply it's not just the idea that
he is the dead letter or the dead
tradition that that brought about you he
is the living source of all things and
he is the living source of you and so
you could say that the heavenly father
is the one that will resurrect you if
you sacrifice yourself
to save your dead father if you
sacrifice yourself to cover the sins of
your father then you will be lifted up
by your heavenly father the spirit of
the father will lift you up and so this
is of course i think a good way to
understand
how there is a clear distinction
in the christian tradition between the
fallen father and the heavenly father um
and and and that the heavenly father is
the true father is the source of all
things it's that which everything leads
leads to and
so it's not just that we as
the sons let's say or that christ as the
son of god ultimately
is there to actualize the dead stuff
that's in re-actualize the dead stuff
that is in the the ground although that
is something that christ does every time
christ says you know
shows the meaning of the law every time
the christ says this is the root you
know this is the the all of the law is
contained in this you know all the laws
contained love god and love your
neighbor what he's doing is he's
actually breathing life back into the
law he's showing how the law is not just
a bunch of stuff you do but that there's
a principle there's a core there's a
logos behind all these rules which if
you find the logos if you find the
principle will illuminate the rules and
will also make the rules secondary to
that to that logo that that is of course
uh definitely something
that christ is doing but the
actualization of this dead past or the
actualization of the dead man or the
dead law all of these things that christ
is doing has to be rooted in something
else it has to be rooted in heaven it
has to be rooted in the source of all
good so it's not just about you know
it's not just about actualizing it
for whatever reason it's actualizing it
towards the good towards the source of
all good and so this is why you know
christ is always saying things like that
he doesn't do his own will he doesn't do
because you could actualize the past in
a very manipulative way you could look
at these
these laws and these things this
tradition that has had has been given to
us and you could try to steer it in a
way
which is only to manipulate it toward
your increase in power you know and you
see that happening all the time that's
how tyrannical systems you know become
you know come to be
that's how people twist things twist
what you've said twist what they read
you know in order to bring about their
own agenda but christ can only
actualize the dead adam resurrect the
dead adam you know in the name of the
ultimate good in the name of the
heavenly father so you can see the
difference between this idea of the
source of all things the father as the
source of all things and the dead father
which is indeed what what you see in the
way jordan interprets it as this kind of
dead uh you know this tradition or these
things that have accumulated all these
things that we've received from the past
that are fallen and need to be
you know remembered in order to be
brought back together but without the
notion of a heavenly father then
this idea of just paying attention and
of that they're remembering these dead
things
could be done in a way that's
manipulated but you need it to be
pointed towards the highest good and the
image of the source of all things that
is the heavenly father is of course the
ultimate version of that
and so i think it's really important to
understand that because if you try to
interpret the father the god the father
in the
in the notion of the christian trinity
as this dead tradition then you're going
to run into many many problems you're
going to run into the fact that that's
just not what it is and that's just not
the way it's presented in the in the
tradition in the christian tradition and
so you'll have to you have to force it
you have to twist it in order to make it
that um but if you do understand adam as
being exactly that then it all kind of
comes together and you don't have to
twist the tradition in order to bring
about the story you don't have to make
the the notion of god the father say
something that no christian theologian
no no christian thinker would ever have
said in the past and so i hope this is
helpful uh both in showing how i think
the the insight that jordan takes from
the story of pinocchio and and the whale
and the story of of course osiris and
horus is really wonderful and he's
really helpful for us today but that
there is of course the a christian
version which also includes the notion
of the source of all good as being that
towards which that for which the son
acts in
healing in resurrecting and you know
bringing
putting shedding light on the meaning of
the things below so i hope this was
useful for everybody to kind of
understand and uh i talk to you very
soon bye-bye
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your uh usual podcast platform but we
also have a website with a blog and
several very interesting articles by
very intelligent people that have been
thinking about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects we also have a clips channel a
facebook group you know there's a whole
lot of ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and the
discussion of symbolism don't forget
that my brother matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please go
ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support